[Musique]
s'asseoir mais de plus en plus
populaires parce que les gens commencent
à avoir une plus grande conscience
environnementale et de consommation
locale
vous permettez vraiment de réduire
vraiment votre impact vous vous
permettez de réduire vos déchets réjean
simard pense que c'est mal trope le vrac
est ce que le fait d'offrir des aliments
dans un format nouveaux vont nous mettre
plus à risque d'être mal à l'achat
d'aliments en vrac est de plus en plus
populaire les surfaces agrandissent
l'offre se diversifie
alors que 90 % des canadiens veulent
réduire leurs emballages alimentaires et
qu'ils en viennent avec leurs contenants
mais sinon ça se passe avec des
cuillères ou des spatules
c'est pas un remplissage qui est 100%
sans degor intéressant du point de vue
environnemental
mais le phénomène amène aussi son lot de
questionnements concernant la salubrité
des aliments que jean souvent parce que
c'est mal trope le vrac que elles
étaient toutes ces mélanges ensemble que
la qualité des produits est pas là mais
en fait c'est complètement faux c'est
vraiment notre responsabilité à nous les
epci de s'assurer que les aliments
soient de qualité de 1 mais aussi de
d'éduquer les gens et de les amener à
bien se servir en vrac site monde
respecte soeur vers la pop province
selon le ministère de l'agriculture des
pêcheries et de l'alimentation du québec
les épiciers sont en effet responsables
de la salubrité des aliments
la loi sur les produits alimentaires
encadre la pratique en plus d'informer
les clients
il faut parfois les suivre pas à pas et
beaucoup de règles à suivre
on sait pas où nous sont les outils
quels sont les outils ya tellement de
produits qui on sait pas par où
commencer non plus donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est là pour éduquer les clients
règle numéro 1 la propreté de nos
contenus ce soir que la responsabilité
du client c'est d'apporter des
contenants trope cible à voir des
produits qui reste frais dans ces
contenants mais pour l'épicier c'est à
nous de leur offrir des produits qui ont
été bien traitées biens entreposés qui
sont dans des contenants propres qui ont
eu la rotation 'achat' et rehaussé
c'est une responsabilité qui est donc
partagée règle numéro 2 un instrument
pour chaque aliment l'épicier décide de
la méthode
ici il n'ya aucun ustensiles devant les
bacs
sûrement une pelle ou une pince pas
reproduit donc admettons qu'on voudrait
du cnoa ok on prendra ce thème à l'appel
ce titre lui même en chinois exactement
donc mettons on prend la quantité qu'on
a besoin pour bouger tromper le pauvre
comme ça ensuite on va disposer de
l'appel nous on a un bac appel
sall a fait donc on vole maintenant avec
l'entonnoir aussi donc si vous prenez
exemple des amendes au chocolat ça colle
trop vite que vraiment c'est avec 50
dollars d'amendé au chocolat on est
responsable de l'otan a ajouté au fait
pas les remettre dans le pool jamais
donc comme un petit qui on peut pas
faire j'ai trop de farine dans mon
contenant leurs maîtres dans l'autre
sens et c'est non dans du moment que
c'est d'un contenant c'est à vous nous
rencontrons la microbiologiste evelyne
guévremont chercheuse en salubrité des
aliments vous dirais qu'en ce moment il
n'y a aucune évidence scientifique qui
nous permet de croire qu'on serait plus
à risque de tomber malade en consommant
des aliments qu'on aurait acheté en vrac
comparativement des aliments qu'on
aurait acheté dans un emballage fourni
par la compagnie donc il n'y a pas de
raison de s'alarmer qu'on va être plus
malades
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut
s'assurer de bien manipuler ces aliments
et de respecter les bonnes pratiques ont
fait en droit tient lavabo julie arrive
souvent ce genre de choses
oui c'est pour ça qu'on aime être
présent quand même du remplissage
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a les bacs
pour recueillir les dégâts dégainer le
lavabo pour pouvoir nettoyer les
contenants des clients ou les bouteilles
on leur donne des balises plus strict
pour s'assurer qu'ils aiment le moins de
contamination croisée possible on parle
souvent de la contamination croisée les
aliments frais sont par nature plus
contaminés que des aliments plus sec
donc si on met en contact des aliments
secs avec des aliments frais on pourrait
à ce moment le contaminer nos aliments c
pour limiter davantage la contamination
croisée l'épicier peut décider de
remplir pour voulait beaucoup comme pour
le beurre de noix pourquoi parce que
vraiment qu'elles sont genf manipulation
et un bar de noix faut que ce soit bien
brasser puis leur faut prendre un cutter
ont filé une façon de faire pour ne pas
contaminer le
le reste ou encore la mayonnaise qui
plus fragiles à la contamination
donc on veut avoir un contrôle parfait
son niveau du gène de l'outil avec
lequel il va être servi de la surface
sur laquelle va être servi d'autres font
même tout le remplissage pour vous comme
ici chez beaucoup beaucoup
c'est le principe de la consigne voilà
comme une crainte que la consigne ne se
soit pas propre
mais dans le fond une bouteille de bière
elle va être tourné jusqu'à six fois
puis quand tu vas au restaurant mais tu
vas pas dire abel la personne avant moi
la manger dans cette assiette
une fois que c'est passé dans la
vaisselle pic s'est assaini le vocal il
ressort il est propre
règle numéro de poids différentes
sections dans l'épicerie c'est important
que les activités reliées à la
manipulation des aliments soient séparés
donc ayant un endroit dédié au lavage
les aliments qui est un endroit dédié à
l'entreposage des éléments ont réduit le
risque de façon générale dans
l'établissement un produit qui effraie
va pas être en finale hier qu'un produit
qui siècle peut-être pas sur les mêmes
zones non plus avec les mêmes outils
on va avoir le lait le yogourt points
dans la même section le ménager dans une
section les jeunes dans une section les
fruits séchés ensemble les noix ensemble
c'est pour faciliter finalement le
voyage dans la boutique si vous voulez
la dernière règle poser des questions
pour s'assurer des bonnes pratiques en
place dans l'établissement et pour
établir la confiance en son épicier puis
commencer tranquillement pour mieux
réussir
selon carol ann de commencer un pot à la
fois aussi simple que ça c'est vrai que
ça peut être frustrant de vouloir tout
faire en même temps que le tas les
petites pattes pas pour traverser à son
propre rythme la transition vers le zéro
déchet cydia
[Musique]